do
what's going on guys let me make sure
that uh
things aren't too loud here let me turn
this up a little bit
turn
turn this down a little bit actually
all right so things should be fine there
we should be good
i don't know though
i want my mic to be a lot louder than
the game but i don't want the game
to where you guys can't hear the game
either
maybe
just maybe
i have to check my phone
i'll have to check my phone
because the chat will wait to the very
end to tell me
[Applause]
my phone we good
i think we are fine
turn this all the way down i don't want
these up on my ears too much
i try to be comfortable for the stream
guys
trying to be comfortable for the stream
we got things we got to do today
now you guys know how i usually do i'll
give you guys one stream on the iop
channel but i do think from here on out
after i do the one stream on the iop
channel i'm gonna start taking
uh
the streams in general to
to twitch
but i'm gonna give you one stream on
here
so if you want more
you guys know where to go
guys know exactly what i'd be talking
about i i'm okay with having a manual
first things gotta go take this alpha
base
now i did do the beginning part
because i've already seen it
and i didn't want
some of you
to get like spoiled on that first
cutscene
so
i did the beginning two missions
not too much of the game but
i did do them
had had to be courtesy man had had had
to have some
courtesy i believe that's the the phrase
i'm looking for it might not be i don't
know
i'd like to get a vehicle
is there vehicles around here or am i
alone
i guess there's no vehicles around here
i could have sworn there's a vehicle
i'm currently playing through on
legendaries not hard as you think it
isn't i will agree with you uh
the game difficulties not hard for the
most part the only things that you'll
ever have like real
hard times with on this game
is you'll have a lot of issues when it
comes to the like the bosses
because the bosses can definitely
mess you up if you let them
another thing that i can really
recommend you guys is like get good
on how you interact with certain of the
like how you do the the grappling hook
you guys really want to learn how to do
that pretty good too
got a spartan four
we need those spartan cores the spartan
cores are important chad they're
important
oh
they sleep
a ravager i like the ravangers
let me go ahead and
with me uh
this out
ow
i died because i was tweeting stuff
oh i can't believe i just did that
oh my god
i got destroyed there man i ain't gonna
lie but but to be fair you guys saw me i
i was
i was i was at my pc
i was no longer looking at
anything else i was wanting to make sure
i handled my business
all right so yeah okay you can't hear
though okay we're good we're good
i like the trees in halo infinite
because you can grapple off them pretty
easy
oh
come on come on you little grunts
let's go
[Music]
the ravager i actually like that weapon
it's not a bad weapon
the ravanger's pretty decent weapon
all right
i think i'm
the good thing about halo infinite is
like it's a really open game so if like
you can
if you can think about it nine times out
of ten you can do it hold up let's test
those
let's test it completely
all right all right let's try that again
try that again
all right this ain't working this ain't
working
let me get on this side
all right i ain't doing that again
clearly that ain't working either
hold up
okay
let's try that again
all right so now we want what we want to
do
is we want to go up here
kind of gives me like a skyrim feeling
if that makes sense to you guys you know
like in the old skyrim games
see but you can leave the battlefield
uh you just got to make sure you don't
cross
out so we got to go this way
all right let's see if we can
if we can do it
no it doesn't look like it's gonna let
us
oh god
let's just go this way
this should be the way
oh the heat wave i actually like this
weapon the heat wave i like it in
multiplayer a lot
i think it's a solid weapon
have you found your first skull no i
didn't actually
what i'm not really a skull person
dog with a cool saxophone i'm not really
a skull person so i didn't really look
for the skulls if that makes sense
like i never really cared about the
schools
i have definitely
went over one of these buildings before
hold up
i can tell where the first one that uh
where is it at i am
where is it at
can i get on top of these
hold up
oh
oh see
i think it's cool you can get on top of
these they shouldn't
like limit you from running on top of
them
i'm going the wrong way
i did hear about that easter egg
i'm curious i did hear about that easter
egg
all right so let's actually
let's be a little bit more serious
all right so we got to go over here
definitely be interested in getting that
but it's like i said you guys like what
i'm gonna start doing
yeah
internet
this is
this is the bass that i'd be talking
about
i like the heat wave i'm gonna keep it
but that spike be a little bit a little
bit lp
like we gotta be a little honest man
that spike be a little bit lp
the skull is right there
i'm curious where you mean where the
skull is
i don't know
uh we already i think we already have
some trolls in the chat
we already got trolls in the chat and he
been streaming for more than 20 minutes
and we already got controls in the chat
i love the music man
that's
beautiful isn't it
it's a really pretty decent sized map
i was created to lock down cortana but i
don't know why
we can go ahead and skip that
because i think you guys want to see the
game play more than anything
all right so now we're on the uh the
right side of the map
let's go to this golf one up here
look down there we're close to the fog
we detected
you take out those monsters
get me to that terminal
and show what i can do
oh
okay maybe i need to be a little bit
more
reserved and not just go straight for
the kill
yeah okay okay let's do let's let's try
that again
look down there we're close to the fob
we detected
you take out those monsters
get me to that terminal
and i'll show what i can do
oh
oh
oh
here hold this
hold this
oh what is that it's a
all right so i ran out of ammo with that
[Music]
you're an idiot why would you come over
there
okay so i think i could take this over
no i can't
oh
that was interesting
i meant to use the grappling hook just
to get closer to him
what's up
where is
now to business let's lock down fob golf
i think i got to turn off my sound
yes i was right all right all i need to
do is chat with a banished security
protocol and by chat i mean push it out
of the way because it is really not
smart sit i really like that about
weapons she just got such a sense of
humor on her was that you
affirmative
so what you're going to just rebuild the
unfc piece by piece
that's his call i'm just trying to be
helpful this is the switch
each fob seems to be linked to the
battle net
and if i do this
we can piece together what the banished
are up to
see this is a decent system i just felt
like they should have expanded on the
system with what they did but it is a
decent system and i enjoyed it worth
looking into and blowing up
and here is what i can only describe as
someone at the banished value
highly
noted
his bio is
interesting if you want to see for
yourself it's waiting for you in the
database
they're tracking unsc transponders too
caches containing valuable i got to get
those spartan cores i want to upgrade
that a lot more than i did when i played
the review
trying to survive
they need your help chief
i will help everybody this time
what do you think
i already told you i aim to please we're
helping everybody guys we're helping
everybody let's go find out what that
signal is
oh we only got the sidekick that's all
i figured at least have an assault rifle
i mean there is an assault rifle right
here so
i guess we don't have a whole lot to
worry about let's go over here and take
this one first
oh i love it it's so satisfying
but not when you hit stuff like that
that's not satisfying
uh
the open world formula don't fit halo to
be honest i mean but
explain to me oj90 why you think it
doesn't because to me halo's always been
like a battlefield
so to me if if it's a good
that can you hear that
i'm on her communication tower
this is like a propaganda tower
get you a little bit of that uh foe
thing or what a valor gets a little bit
of valor
and pretty much valid just lets you
unlock stuff
uh
proactively where you don't have to like
go look for it
we could use an lz in this region
forget the banish i love the grunts the
grunts have always
been a very vocal part of uh of halo
[Music]
pick that up
it's being a little too much
chief let's capture that bob
being a little too open with it man a
little too open
oh
man they're everywhere
oh he dropped that grenade that was that
was interesting i've never noticed him
do that
[Music]
got him
i don't really have much ammo left
i'm gonna have to snatch this
it's somebody to guess five of open
world
i i wouldn't necessarily say that that
it's similar to gears 5. i feel like
gears 5 probably did the open world
thing a little bit better
if they would have just got certain
things
i actually prefer the open world and how
they did it in gears 5 more i know
people didn't like that open world but i
actually enjoyed it
oh my god get out of the tree
[Music]
if that makes sense to you guys
i think that's all of them get me to
that terminal and bob foxtrot is ours
got it
okay there's a lot of people that liked
it there was
if you guys are referring to the open
world of this game
the closer we can the stronger the unsc
distress signal becomes there's a lot of
people that i felt like enjoyed uh this
what was going on in
in halo 2 i mean in gears as well so i
don't think it's just like a one all fit
thing
apologize for the sneezing guys
this is not a bad weapon i just
i just don't like it
all right let's just get
let's just get it
but i mean oj like i all due respect
like have you played this that what much
i know it just came out today
like
i feel like i understand where you're
coming from
but
there's a difference between other
people saying something on the internet
and you try it yourself if that makes
sense
oh yeah i know it's an audio log
i'm going for this uh picked up a unsc
distress signal this unc distress caller
suggests a squad of marines
alive
no response on comms but if they are
it's a sure bet they need our help
let's find breathe
oh god i even know this behind me
oh it's a br let's go
[Music]
i appreciate the uh 75 super chat from
danger uh uxo love the great content you
and the rest of the team have been
putting out thanks for all the hard work
happy holiday
we we try man we really do and i really
appreciate the uh the support man
i appreciate you guys even being here
watching it because i know we're not
like a real live streaming thing
but uh you know
to watch someone play a game is a
different set feat if that makes sense
to you guys
but i definitely appreciate the uh
i always save your ass no
so you want this to share it because
like
there's certain aspects in this game
that
if you have those unlocked it's a lot
easier to take care of
i've already done it we leaving
i like there's no fall damage too
it's nice that there's no fall damage
when you guys play the game if you jump
right when you connect with the with
the ground on the grappling hook you can
actually like thrust yourself up a
little bit i don't know if you guys
noticed that or not
how did you live
that was a little weird
i get what you're saying like
you're a purist
you're entitled to your opinion man i'm
not gonna tell you
you can't oh my god
oh that is not what i wanted to do
all right all right we're good we're
good we're good all right
even after all they've endured these
marines just won't give up
neither will
we oh he was falling asleep
bg he he
he's family but
you know i get it everyone's stream
isn't for everyone
i'm sure some people see my stream and
they say they gonna fall asleep too man
let me grab this no come over here
that's a rocket launcher let's go
check that out
yeah get in you too
wasn't there three of you
yeah there's three
let's go i hate this so much jump in
there we go
oh there's another one of these things
there we go over here
well you guys shouldn't have got out
all right let's go
there's three of them
we're gonna go over here
we're gonna go ahead and clear this area
next
this weapon this vehicle here is like
really good because it's so
defensive
got to find the best way of getting to
the it looks like we're going to have to
go through
this heat to get to where i need to go
i mean we can go through the key it
ain't it ain't nothing to go through the
keep
so let's go ahead and go through the
keep first
[Music]
oh my gosh let's go through this keep
i do feel like
the world
i know people
are speculating on how big the world
really is but to me you guys like i feel
like the world's big enough like i never
felt like
i felt like sometimes because of the the
limitations in traveling
unless you get like the fov thing up
like
uh to the valor so you can get more
stuff i know i've never felt like
like i was so over
uh over uh underwhelmed
yeah let's open the gate clearly
so what are you going to do about it
just we want that gate open
nice you need to manually raise each
silo first yeah yeah yeah i know i know
match
oh my god
hold this
oh
that was
that was definitely by accident
i'm surprised i lived through that
each fuel silo should have a manual
override
yeah yeah right now the only thing i'm
worried about is killing these things
oh commando
oh got a rocket launcher next
let's go
all right so that was a waste of a
rocket that's fine now
all right let's find
there's one over here
i'mma call [ __ ] on that one
i don't know what that was about
each fuel silo should have a manual
override
about to die again
[Music]
i don't want you shooting that rocket
i need
to grapple
there we go
let's go ahead and raise this up
silos rinsed
[Music]
just gotta shoot it randomly until it
blows up
i don't like how they all blow up the
same way though
i've always just grapple hooked the
jackals i've always felt like that was a
decent way
getting by all that
there you go
i really suck at that
[Music]
oh
man how many more much more damages can
this thing take
[Applause]
i mean i'm shooting the thing left and
right and there's just nothing happening
to him
yeah yeah yeah
where's that sniper coming
from sniper gonna do some damage to me
all right all right all right
[Music]
gotcha
the disruptor's not that bad i probably
should grab it since i've ran out of
ammo
that sniper gotta go
[Music]
i gotta get close to this sniper
[Music]
there we go
i don't think i was able to really do
any damage to him
yeah snipers can get it
we ain't worried about those snipers
but we do need more of these little
things
there we go
let's just go and open this one up too
you know what to do now
destroy that silo jesus
i don't know if you can
destroy it with this but we're gonna
just shoot it over and over again until
it blows up
oh it takes so much ammo this is all i
have thank you
steps
spam your ass with grenades
give me that
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go there's that
we've got company chief well someone's
talking [ __ ] about the grappling hook it
looks like the banished are tearing down
and repairing vehicles here
not for long
marking the repair bays
let's do this
someone talking [ __ ] about the grappling
hook
all right where is if i remember
correctly there's an elite here yeah
right there
yeah i knew he was gonna get me the
moment i switched and i saw i had that
stupid-ass gun
let me switch something real quick
there we go
where is he
yeah
what
that was ridiculous
i had that
where is he where is he
where is he
yeah give me that sword
people want to mess with me now okay
i got a sword now
let's blow this up
then we go jump on
this nice little scorpion are the
banished digging for something we're
going to do a little bit of damage with
the scorpion
he could take a
it could take that
oh
man the scorpions already took some
damage
oh
all right let's get out
[Music]
takes a little bit of damage not too
much though
and that's
that was that of it
like i said not too bad
ransom jeep is officially offline
we did it chief oh god
oh my god that was close
what does he have 16
we're gonna keep what we have
we can always go over here
this next dude is a is
a pain in the ass
but it is one of the most unique uh
helpful weapons to do
yeah yeah yeah
they always be talking that smack but
ain't nothing to help the man
all right let's go down
are you gonna see audio log
now we're gonna have to end up fighting
uh a whole platoon of people here in a
minute
so that's gonna be
it's gonna be a little complicated but i
think
i think we'll get we'll get it done
i don't have a sniper but i'm used to
this sword to handle the dude that
that i have to handle
i'm gonna go over the ridge too i went
under it before
but i feel like
to be more successful at this we might
want to go over it instead of going
under it because there's a lot more
places
to uh manage up here
akro vaga dune is nearby chief be
careful he's got quite a rap sheet
thousands of unsc personnel died at his
hands
he's got a sword
i remember there's like a sniper up here
somewhere
yeah i get that but part of me is like
did the butt
did these really have biomes like that
i don't remember halo rings like being
like snow biomes and stuff
oh look at you
he sniped me
yeah you guys can go last the sniper
gotta go now
yeah we can't let you be shooting me
with that
where is that is he gonna come up here
to me
halo 3 flood level had snow
yeah i remember that now that you bring
that up i do remember that
because i mean they do have their own
atmosphere so it would make sense if
some of them would have snow and stuff
uh he's down there somewhere
i feel like going up there is
he's gonna get us killed
it's gonna get us killed if we go down
there right now
okay
let's do it
i gotta focus on the dude with the sword
i'm really nervous about going down
there uh because he's got that sword
because they could kill you pretty easy
on here
he's right there
so let's go kill this sniper first
because i really need this
we need this
come on
come on
i'm waiting
oh what i get stopped by
what i get hit by
i don't i personally i don't mind it but
halo fans want snow or desert i agree
they need more biomes
the map could have shown more diversity
in terms of uh where you play no one's
good i don't think and i don't think
anyone's really arguing that and if they
are arguing that then you know they they
need to
be more realistic
uh
where'd he go
come on
i wish they would come up here to me
[Music]
i don't think he die yeah he's dead he's
dead okay okay
let's just take our time killing them
[Music]
oh he's a sniper
come on get those shields back
come on get my shield get the shields
yeah yeah yeah come here
gotcha
there's some people over here i don't
think we have to worry about too much
it is a you know it could be a difficult
game in certain scenarios but the game's
not a hard game it's just there's
certain scenarios that can be hard
oh this there's someone up there
i like the skewer
i don't like it in pvp but i like it in
pve
it's pretty diverse in pve
[Laughter]
i got a little bit more enjoyment out of
that than i should have you cheated
you're nothing but a cheater
i really like that that was funny crew
eliminated life on this ring just got a
little safer for the unsc
hey did you get a look at that modified
weapon the target was carrying pretty
inventive even for the banished so i
copied it
i've sent updated schematics back to our
forward operating bases should give us
an edge
ah we can use the scare thank you card
for the upgrade but you killed the
intended recipients yeah the grunts are
good man you think we're gonna yes we
will get a firefight mode i'm very
pretty confident we'll get one of those
eventually
you cheated i love that man i really
really got a kick out of that grunt i
really got a kick out of that grunt guys
that was that was a that was a fun thing
chad
look how long
i do wish that they would let me unlock
like
flying vehicles sooner
because right now i'm just walking
around
is
yeah yeah
this is pretty blane
i mean you don't have to
to play it man
was that
unfc distress pulls detected
more marines in trouble
yeah yeah
get these marines out of harm's way
shoot
oh
hill a little bit
that those snipers are deadly man
that's where the uh
the unsc is
let me free them real quick
[Music]
yeah yeah
oh sniper
[Music]
i love to get a little bit more health
than just half an inch or something
there we go
all hostels eliminated glad we made it
in time
there we go
got a little bit more stuff
we can't get over there yet because we
have to do this thing here this tower
there is another
there is some more people we could save
i think no we completed that
let's teleport there
yeah that's the flaws of most open world
games i do agree with you they could
have did a little bit
more with the open world
i will agree with you on that
all right so let's go over
here
it seems like he's got a a weird
pistol i don't know what that is but
we're gonna go check it out chat we're
gonna go check it out
the island dog is really good that ai
even picks up guns if missed opportunity
yeah uh that cereal i picked uh i
dropped it on accident
and when i went to look for it it was
already gone and one of the marines had
it so
they definitely will pick stuff up if
you don't pick it up
[Music]
i guess tower was a more than
appropriate name
look at that place
the signals coming from within that main
structure
yeah we got to get up there
there's a boss up there
yeah yeah yeah
there's a boss up there in that
structure guys i'll get to him here in a
minute though
there's a lot of enemies in that
structure to be honest with
you lot of enemies in there
[Music]
hvt and range chief this one's a
particularly murderous grunt high
sumpter bricklard
oh there he is most wanted don't
underestimate him geez
but we're not finished yet get the crew
[Music]
i kind of underestimated him and it
didn't like blow up in my face
oh my
god i knew i was done i couldn't get
close enough
what more would you
learn from the open world
what i want
you have to
break that up a little bit more daniel
hill
exactly what you mean by
that
hvt and range chief this one's a
particularly murderous grunt high
sumpter bricklord
he's one of the usc's most wanted don't
underestimate him chief
yeah
we could talk about that here in a
second let me kill him again
and we'll we'll talk about that
hvt eliminated now take out the rest of
the squad
oh god
can i go up here
[Music]
oh this is where you were
they're everywhere guys
[Music]
oh he moved right at the last minute
that was unfortunate
oh
got you
got you
i think that's how the saying goes
anyway that's the last of briglard and
if his bio is we'll talk about the open
world in general
we'll make it like a little chat all
right so let's let's let's stop here for
a second
as you can see i ain't playing on the
road
and let me go
let me close out of
of discord
all right so let's let's break down a
little bit when it comes to halo
infinite all right so this is this is
the the chill and talk episode one
of the the halo infinite stream
i just started on heroic difficulty
loving this so far feels so good let's
talk about the open world
of halo infinite
now
there are certain things that i feel
like they could have done better with
the open world
as you can see that we just saw you
actually did fight a mob that was just a
name
there are some that look different
but for the most part they give them
like a unique armor
or something relative like that and then
what they do is like
let's just go ahead and give them a a an
upgraded weapon so
hold up let me go back to the game real
quick
now here's how i would have wanted it
now if you look here you'll see
the targets
this is the place where all the targets
that i have just killed i killed two of
them uh the this one and the do and the
the the grunt with the plasma pistol
so how i would have liked to have done
instead of doing
well how many is that
sick four eight twelve
okay so it looks like this 15. so
instead of doing 15 targets
they should have did like five
key generals in the banished army and
like they could have been like i would
rather have
five
well fleshed out side missions that lead
up to killing these these targets then
just throwing 15 random targets out in
the world that you just go and kill now
i'm not saying this this system didn't
work
it is a fun system because they all give
you like a unique weapon
and there's a lot of things that you can
do like i can't say that they got that
wrong because i i don't think i think
saying they got that wrong is unfair
because i do think that they did
enough to where makes me feel like it's
fun but
i do feel like if they would have just
limited the amount of targets you had
and really build on these targets and
get like like like i said like five
really good side characters like when
you're doing the side characters it's
constantly updating you on
how this individual in the banished army
was one of the key factors that led to
the unsc getting completely demolished
before this game took place like kind of
like goes to sushima
you know how in goshama when you're
playing that game
uh you're doing the side missions on
your allies and it keeps evolving that
side mission throughout the time
i felt like it could have been something
like this in here where instead of your
allies is doing it to
like certain generals or certain figures
that's in the banished army
and every time
you get a certain amount done what ends
up happening is they let they they
explain why that individual was so
dominant in the army
and i feel like something like that
would have really helped uh because i
don't mind the target system
i just felt like it could have done
better like they even say here like you
know they give a little bit of a uh like
a description
of what
they
they were known for
but i would have preferred a little bit
more in detail where you know cut scenes
really going into
why you should fear this person and you
guys saw how quick i took both of them
out sure the first one gave me a little
bit more uh
a little bit more
what's what i'm looking for the first
one was a little bit harder than the
second one because of just the angle i
was in
but neither one of them are hard
neither one of them really give you
issues
that'd be core just something to be more
targets than just hitting them
with your gun
yeah yeah maybe but to me like in order
to do that you're gonna have to have
like
they did give them a bio and i'm not
going to say they didn't do that
but to me
the biome is good it gives lore it
explains certain things
but imagine like
to start these side missions you come
across like like uh marines that
survived like a camp or something that
these people are in charge of these
individuals that i'm talking about they
could have done and you have to do these
side missions to to get a good example
of where they're going to be you don't
know where they're at at the map and
then once you do it like you do that
that last mission that lets you go and
kill them
yeah i don't know about the nemesis
system
i would actually like microsoft to buy
wb games just for that nemesis system if
i'll be real with you guys i would have
really liked that
i feel like that nemesis system is so
underrated
it's not that i want a cut scene there
uh
i just wanted you know
more build up anticipation
to fighting these individuals
i mean we can even go on the uh the
valor and the fob thing like pretty much
as much value you get what happens is
you have access to these
these
technology when you're
yeah i get you have access to these
technology when you actually get there
so you got you guys know like i got the
pistol that's because i have enough to
get the pistol but you keep you know
freeing people doing this doing that and
then you know your store unlock more and
more of these type of vehicles and stuff
and i like what they did there i do i i
like it it's a nice little system
but i feel like it needed to be expanded
a little bit more i feel like when it
comes to the fob system we needed a
little bit more of a
like an emphasis on why you should do
this like that's why i brought up in my
review
definitely go check out the uh my review
on this game uh it's on this channel uh
i would have liked a little bit more in
depth in how this system would work for
instance
let's say that
there's a bar down here
below it you see the bar down there how
it lights up when you do it like let's
say that's just a regular bar you're not
going to put it anywhere else and when
you get that the higher that bar is
the more presence the unsc is on the map
and then like let's say they do like a
final battle and if you have that maxed
you have a lot more help with you into
that final battle and the unsc show up
in warthogs with rocket launchers and
they show up in um you know hornets or
whatever those things are called what do
they call it again
wasps they show up in wasps and they
help you fight the last battle and i
feel like just something like that would
have been a lot would have been cool i
would have liked it like like to give me
a reason that i want to go around the
map and do all this stuff that when it
comes to the very final
battle if you did everything you could
with the fob and got is maxed out valor
that you're going to be taking these
people that you've been saving
throughout the game and you're going to
be taking all this map advantage that
you've been doing throughout the game
and you're going to go into the final
battle with it and i i would like that
that would be cool
oh it has boss fights
i'm talking about like a final
like a final push
[Music]
they aren't paid upgrades you earn valor
in game i don't think i'm not saying
they're paid upgrades maybe you're
talking to someone in the chat
oh they know i'm here
let's take all all the problems
what's up
what's up
we're gonna throw this
i didn't say you could pay for the
pistol i said that there is a currency
in the game
that when you get it high enough you can
spawn with the pistol you could spawn a
pistol look at chris righteous trying to
not chris righteous chris hart trying to
paint a narrative that i never said
say it ain't so chris say it ain't so
i still got a little bit left in that
oh
let me get that shotgun
yeah the grappling hook is really good
[Music]
oh
oh man i got stuck on that
but i hope you guys understand what i'm
saying i hope you do
so the demon is here
man the snipers really don't play
yeah yeah
probably gonna get killed because that
sniper
[Music]
i gotta read that here in a second
uh you have to give me a second that's a
lot of information that you just put up
on the screen
let me finish this little part here then
then i'll see what you're talking about
man
got to kill the
snipers first
i think not
my facility is locked down
he seems confident
yes he does but fortunately it's
misplaced when the lockdown triggered
there was a power spike in what i
presume was a security building
i've marked it on the map
oh my god i missed two shots
all right jared i'm four hours in could
not be more displeased so far boring
uninspired completely
devoted any restoration i wish they've
taken more time and better direction
this just isn't halo
like
i get so annoyed when people say this
isn't halo
like all right all right all right jared
let's break this down what's that look
let's break it down jared what's
happening
tell me jared what's halo to you jared
what's halo jared i need i need that
answer in my life i need what you think
halo is
about to die again
ghost also had character stories as well
in the crap side missions
halo is titan count as a story being
told
but there is a story here is it because
like
i mean i get it like so
i'm not happy with certain aspects of
the story either but to say it's not
halos just like kind of
kind of missing me a little bit with
that
[Music]
wow
i keep getting killed by these things
man
you have to explain a little bit of that
to me jared i got i i gotta understand
what you mean
cuz i really don't understand what you
mean
educate me jared
i want to see the light
[Music]
completely out of weapons
[Music]
what's up man
i need this
being out of ammo is pretty uh pretty
bad
oh what is this yeah won't you guys join
the fight
i'll get to you in a second jared
i see you responding jared
i see you responding jared
i haven't forgot about you jared
oh my god that was like an excessive
amount of sharks
my power
i think not
my facility is locked down
there is nothing you can do here
except
die
i feel like they did this dude pretty
good
now if only they they all had
like kind of like little side missions
like this
when the lockdown triggered there was a
power spike in what i presume was a
security building
i've marked it on the map
all right here's the security building
this is where the lockdown was triggered
he's still not dead
got that shotgun
he's got a rocket launcher
i don't know i feel about him having a
rocket launcher
[Music]
in the lockdown
it's pretty easy to end the lockdown i'm
not gonna lie to you guys the lockdown
protocol should be simple to reverse let
me see three two one
done
oh
what is it
this
this place this facility station
facility run by our elite friend back
there check lock
his reputation is i will get to the chat
here in a minute i hear i see
the conversation that chat's lit right
now
let me let me finish
let me grab this rocket launcher from
homeboy
you're going to need to manually
activate the gravity lift i've marked it
on your map
this location acts as a holding facility
prisoners are captured funneled through
the chat block and then on to somewhere
they call the house
oh
they they came at me pretty hardcore
how you grapple a monster at seven foot
tall and they don't react naughty
[Music]
no i mean is there a grappling hook like
that naughty dog where like it pulls you
to something
prisoners are captured funneled through
to chest lock and then onto somewhere
they call the house of reckoning see why
do we have to compare another
studio to
this game
you missed me with that man you missed
me with that
all right so it's actually location acts
as a holding facility prisoners are
captured funneled through to check these
things are faster
wow
maybe i just shoot them with a rock at
the moment it starts
they have no way of getting to higher
ends either to be honest with you
this location acts as a holding facility
prisoners are captured funneled through
the chat block and then on to somewhere
they call the house of reckoning which
is
suitably ominous and banished sounding
[Music]
all right so i gotta go over there
i love the game well you know i did i've
already beat the game once
but i do enjoy it and i think they did a
good job
uh obviously we were saying earlier some
of the criticisms i have for the game
that's how it is another reason i bring
up the stuff is because i generally
want the game to be better that's all
like i don't be hating on halo
for for my for my health why don't we
really be hating in general just give
criticisms that i feel like can make the
game better
[Music]
i need that shotgun
oh how'd i miss that
seems like i got one more
that's got a ravager
where is
the dude that was shooting me
remember we can't get up there without
activating the gravity lift yeah yeah
yeah
i know where the gravity lift thing is
is there another one
i could have swore i activated it i'll
think off the
i need to get the higher ground
let's go the gravity lifts powered up
oh
yeah
chief more spartan armor and the source
of the distress signal
were too late
[Music]
they needed another year at least
it appears to be we'll go over your your
opinions here in a second jared
could be useful save the galaxy addict
i don't know what that came from i feel
like that came from something but i
don't know
this armor belonged to a spartan named
hudson griffin
hudson griffin
belonged to a sport named hunson griffin
forcibly
it's a long shot but he might still be
alive i was falling asleep playing this
hope it gets better
like
i'm kind of curious what you guys
expected
like did you expect like a like a last
of us type of halo game
kind of curious what you guys expected
i hope there's not another one of those
things
curious what you guys expected man
wow i didn't even see him till it was
too late
he came at me with the intent to kill
let me ask you guys a question people in
the chat
uh
for those of you that don't know
i did bring up earlier that we are going
i'm gonna start doing
like streaming these big games that i
review like one time on the iop channel
but then i am going to start rotating
stuff to the twitch chest
[Applause]
i'll just beat you with that dude how
many of you like interact with twitch
like what's the best
time to like
stream and stuff on twitch because i i'm
not familiar with the twitch streams
and the twitch grinding in general
i want this red one
oh my god
i hated my eight times he was just
laughing at me
this is not shadow of mourning
it's a good game
i really enjoy shadow mortar
he's
about what you would expect
for an elite
who specializes in torture
are you still alive
how are you not dead
let me see here
voltage i like voltage
there we
go voltage is nice
[Music]
and expose your
yeah got killed by a grunt
they react when getting shot and punched
you can even see the armor getting
knocked off and shot yeah i like that um
i definitely like the detail they put on
some of the
people
i need that mangler yeah
[Music]
[Music]
stop moving
a grenade i got killed by a grenade
again
it's probably the same grenade the same
dude
he literally threw the grenade right
where i was landing
one gonna get killed by a grenade
[Music]
[Music]
disruptor is pretty good i like the
destructor
oh no spartan griffin he's still alive
we need to get him out of there
welcome to my tower master chief
it is where you will be broken
it is where you will give up your
secrets
[Music]
oh here we go
i gotta switch
i gotta switch weapons i mean
i gotta switch um
technology
the walls retracted watch your back he
could come from anywhere
yeah yeah yeah
let me have this
[Music]
um
last time i checked
the rumors or games
some gameplay on certain things
i don't know if i think the acquisitions
might be done for a little bit to be
honest with you guys the wall's
retracted watch your back he could come
from anything i'm okay with that
[Music]
oh
wow
what's up hustle when are you gonna
start streaming
i stream real light to
try my hardest not to like step on
anyone
had to hit him twice a run
he could come from anywhere
clumsy
where is a needler
neither do really good on bosses
i guess your shotgun would be good too
hey let's talk about game award
predictions
what do you what what predictions you
want to talk about man
the wall's retracted watch your back he
could come from anywhere oh my god
[Music]
i appreciate the rage
oh
[Music]
i don't like using the threat sensor
there he is
ah
oh
[Music]
working on it
okay
be ready i'm going to cut him loose
it's you
you're alive that was
that was uh that was a little rough man
that was a little rough
the baddest
i tried to stop them
i try to
easy
you're safe now
the banished they
they have something they call the
conservatory
that's all i
know it's picked up north of here
dig site
i couldn't stop them
but you can
you have to
i don't gotta do [ __ ] fam
that's good
i didn't mind that encounter i thought
it was a good counter maybe they could
have made like spiders like different
phases of it where maybe the map opens
up a little bit more i'll find them
but i didn't mind that encounter
can you hear me i repeat can you hear me
[Music]
that was more like a tutorial boss too
they're trying to tell you how to use
the little sensor thing chief
[Music]
please did you find the source of the
signal whatever is down there either has
to come with us or be left behind
can you hear me
a dig site on the ring
this conservatory must be some sort of
forerunner installation
what do you suppose they're after
what's unique about a cloak elite bullet
sponge i don't think it's necessary
about like
him being like a bullet sponge or
anything like that like he had a shield
if you notice after i took his shield
off and i went to start shooting at him
with his shield off he went down
relatively fast
he thought that he was a bullet sponge
he had a shield on
i'm guessing that whatever the
conservatory is the banished won't want
us anywhere near it
then they'll be disappointed
yes they will
once again jared like what what did you
just curious like what was your
expectations coming into this oh [ __ ]
oh what's going on here
oh i shouldn't have done that
i mean
i guess i understand where you're coming
from
i'm just kidding like
oh the older halos when it comes to boss
fights
i'm just curious exactly what what you
expected with like
older like older boss fights that makes
sense like
what was so special about the older boss
fights why don't you answer to me that
jared
answer me that jared riddle me that
what was so special about the older boss
fights
literally how the hell did jared play
the other games i just finished
i mean he said he played it for four
hours
i mean
it's possible game's been out since like
one that's when you could officially
download it
so it's definitely like possible i just
don't know if it's probably
oh my god i wish i had a long range
weapon of some sort
yes
jared
enlighten us
we're all sitting here waiting for you
jared
show us the way show us the way
we want
to know the way of of jared
we want to know the way of jared
let's go jared
waiting for you
waiting for you to type man
remember the prophet battles or the end
of halo 3 fighting the brutes even the
early
elite battles as arbor and halo 2 was
awesome the profit battles i don't
i get where you're coming from on that
but
i don't know
never felt like the boss fights in that
game was like amazing if that makes
sense
i felt like they were fun but
as far as like being unique i i don't
know if i'd go that far
the banished are searching for something
called the conservatory
let me guess you're heading there too
oops
well don't worry about me
i'll be here waiting here's one alone
we'll be in touch
whoa
i mean he was just asking you know
what your opinion was
i don't know if he was trolling
maybe you see it differently though
maybe you see it differently
i don't personally think he was trolling
jake
uh but you know
i can't tell you how other people
how you take trolling and you don't take
trolling so that's up to you i want to
block people in the chat
it's perfectly up to you jared
i just feel like the the boss fights in
halo ain't never been like that man they
they've been okay but
chat i think we're gonna have to youtube
some boss fights from previous halo what
do you think chad you think we're gonna
have the boss
i think we've got to
you know it's been so long since i
played them maybe i'm just out of touch
with what's going on maybe that's what
it is
[Music]
give me this
oh god come on
oh my god
i'm being too
obsessed with what chad not chad
jared is doing
i want to know more of what he wants god
of war bosses quick time events press
i actually would prefer
some of that in halo like i i don't want
every boss being like that but i do
think that they do
very well
that type of boss fights i think those
are very engaging i think sometimes they
get a little too much with the the the
quick events
but i don't think that
oh god yeah it's time to get up out of
here
but i do enjoy that type of boss fights
i'm not gonna lie
oh god
oh my god all right all right all right
that's it that's it we they going down
let me let me move my mic a little bit
they going down i'm done with this
we about to
destroy them chat we about to
get rid of these people
you're fine without boss fights entirely
i don't know how i feel about that what
we're going to youtube boss fights
here's in a minute
from halo the halo franchise
because i'm very curious
we don't even really got to fight these
people at this bridge
i don't got a long-range weapon and i
don't wanna
i'm
tired of that something called the
conservatory
let me guess i don't know jared's gone i
have uh
but we are still looking up the boss
fights i'm still curious about that
alone
we'll be in touch
look at these boss fights after i do
this little part here for too long
okay
i mean
oh gotta get away
wait
[Music]
i mean he's still here i i see him still
talking
so you know
there's that
it's not like no we're not on like no
disrespecting though we got to make sure
that's clear
it's just jokes
[Music]
into the fold hang on i'm still reading
hostels in the area
that'll do it bob captured we got we got
echo on the edge of the island echo chad
we got echo what used to be a single
contiguous structure
can you imagine the force it would take
to blow this ring apart it must have
been quite a show
all right so let's
let's look it up
let's look up these boss fights in these
previous halos
let's let's find out
how magnificent these these boss fights
have been
i'm curious chat
i'm curious
let's look up these boss fights
all right so let me
um
did they mess up okay
let's look at these boss fights and why
i look at this
give me a second
we're gonna look up these boss fights
because the chat says these boss fights
are lit
and
i'mma need proof i'm gonna need proof
so we're gonna look up these boss fights
and see how that goes
because as of right now
i still need proof
all right so let's
let's look up this all right so we got
on that
actually let's let's make a whole new
thing
let's make a whole new thing
yeah let's
bring this to the other side
i'm bringing this here
so i can still see the chat because we
got we got to still see the chat man we
got still see the chat
all right so let me cancel this
redo it again
there we go
all right so
let's go to youtube
halo
2
boss
fights
now let's go over to it
all right so this is what we're going to
do
we're going to look at some of these
boss fights okay here's what he was
talking about when he fought the brutes
um
brutes versus elites let's let's let's
see what this boss fight is
i don't know if i should show
like the audio
we won't show the audio chat
is this is this is this it chat
is this where we at
this is a good boss fight wasn't it it
was epic it was awesome
literally he's just
hitting him with the sword over and over
again
it's no real
uniqueness to this fight nothing like
that
he's just hitting him with a sword over
and over again
so i'm kind of curious on
the quote-unquote boss factors of this
spot fight
but you know what you know what jared
we'll give you the benefit now
let's look up
halo 3 boss fights
guilty spark
we we all know we all remember guilty
spark don't we
literally shoots you like with three
different beams over and over again
but somehow
this is unique and awesome
but an elite that constantly goes invis
that you have to use equipment to find
to fight and he's got armor and he's got
shields
that's not it but this is
this
this is it right
i'm not saying that this wasn't fun for
its time
but we can't act like this was amazing
gameplay in terms of boss mechanics
because it wasn't
that that's my point
look
did they do an amazing in terms of what
they showed us no they could have
improved everything
every game could have improved
everything i'm sure back then we could
have named 20 different ways this can
improve
but
i don't think
it's fair
to say that you know
that they completely dropped the ball on
stuff because i don't
i don't think they did
you know
i think they could have definitely
improved
but i don't think that
they dropped the ball enough to where me
thinking that these bosses
are so innovative so awesome
to make you think that the other bosses
don't do anything like
i feel like they're they're fun
especially like there's bosses i ain't
fought yet that's really enjoying
enjoyment fighting and it's not saying
anything about
fighting 343 guilty spark or fighting
the elites
in halo 2. those are fun experiences
but
i would have personally liked in in halo
infinite where the bosses evolve and
they change their patterns and the room
changes or something relative to that
nature like you can give that type of
criticism but i i i respect that you
know i respect your opinion regardless
but to me
i feel like
the boss fights are
they they they're unique because
we've nev like we've always had camos
but we've never really fought a boss
fight revolved around camos if that
makes sense like
there's been certain incidences where
they've kind of hinted at it but not to
the degree that we just fought that
individual and there's other individuals
further in the game that i will agree
needed to change things up a little bit
and i do think that we need a little bit
more of a narrative focus when we're
fighting these bosses
uh because if you notice i heard that
dude quite a bit
and
they didn't really necessarily
like
talk to you acknowledge that their
injuries so i can give you that they
should have did better in terms of stuff
like that when we're talking about halo
infinite but i do feel like
they did do a pretty good job on what
they've already showed us and that
that's just my opinion i get it's like i
said jerry you entitled to your opinion
i'm not going to say no because
unlike other people that give their
opinion on halo products i do sense that
you know what you're talking about so
this is strictly just me and you having
a difference of opinion
in terms of how they did it
uh i don't think either one of us are
wrong
oh
if that makes sense to you guys
i hope that makes sense
i might have to change that up a little
bit
because we're going to have to have like
a
a what's what i'm looking for
a little bit of a template for like i
call show and tell we need a little bit
of a show and tell
uh
now let's go back a little bit on um
let's go back a little bit on some of
the chat when i was focusing on the game
on that that's fine uh jared that's why
when people are coming at you in the
chat like i'm not gonna do that because
i have my own
rights with infinite and i definitely
understand if if
there were certain things that you felt
like they could have did and i
understand that i do i'm not going to
say i don't
iron those people expecting more than
just clear area hold x on
another
great criticism there is a lot of that
um i did feel like there was a lot of
like fetch question going on at infinite
it it wasn't enough to where i didn't
feel like it was overburdened but i do
understand that criticism they need to
have a little bit more interaction in
terms of what's going on but i do
understand that criticism
yeah opening is kind of boring and
cortana talking too much
uh the realness i don't know if you're
still in the chat i assume you're
talking about weapon
or are you talking about because i don't
think cortana really talks at the
beginning a whole lot
she does like the whisper things but
that's about all
you said rocket animations
why not stream on youtube all right
here's the youtube thing
uh good question who said that tando
good question why not stream on youtube
iron lord podcasts we're trying to
branch out to other platforms
uh we're starting you know we got a good
following you know the brown's been
really good to us on youtube
but we're trying to expand our horizons
you know uh open up to other places such
as you know twitch and i myself enjoy
streaming
so i personally feel like i don't want
to overburden the youtube channel if
that makes sense i want to make sure
that you know might do a stream or two
on the youtube channel
but
i'll be back when i finish and maybe
spoil the discussion um
before you leave jared do you think that
we at the you think on this channel i
should do a spoiler cast in like a week
two weeks and i'll reach out to some
other you know reviewers that i know
played it and will really break down
the game what they could have improved
on it i'm kind of curious you guys
opinion on that
i think it's gonna it's like i said
earlier i think it's gonna be one of
those things where it's done
on the multiplayer side
uh uh it's gonna it's gonna be done like
destiny does
yeah tando like the thing is like i like
streaming but
i don't want to like overburden the the
youtube channel when you see stream one
stream two iop
attic show like you know we do want our
feed being a little bit clear because we
do respect
you know you guys as you respect your
feed we don't want you to have to on
[Music]
i agree you know it's his it's his
it's jared's opinion if he wants to
block stuff
but you know sometimes things get a
little bit hectic and it's fine you know
we can have these conversations
i don't think it's uh too bad what we
can
what's up
gotcha
picking up reinforcements coming our way
got rockets and stuff going around
trying to get under
i saw him out
of that gun
no more of that
but i'll take yours actually i'll take
this
actually i'll switch you
stop it that's why the marines call you
a legend chief
see we got that taken care of
we got another one over there we can do
that's the activation site
look
as long as the disagreeing in the chat
is respectful you guys can crack jokes
at each other don't take stuff
personally
and don't go for low blows
you can you can make jokes at each other
like that
as long as i'm sure that
there's respect in that conversation
then i'm okay with where the
conversation goes
yeah i got some friends on twitch um
i'm okay at doing the lone streams i
think i i can definitely do it
uh but i i prefer to play games with
people
uh because i like bouncing off of people
but um
we're gonna i get there man i'm gonna
get there
see if i can uh and you know not even
just streaming i just want to play more
multiplayer like more fun co-op
experience games i don't know if some of
you noticed that like occasionally me
uh cognito king
will play like co-op experience games
we'll probably move those to twitch if
that makes sense to you guys
and that will be only streamed on twitch
and i will stream
on youtube
like the first stream like this stream
now
i'm streaming now on youtube
but after this stream
i probably won't stream this game again
on youtube
unless like the lords play something
so like when i review a game because i i
did move my reviews to the iron lords
podcast channel
so when i review a game that's strictly
kevin uh
i think jared left but jared if you're
there
kevin says that he might have been a
little too harsh on you
uh you know if you don't mind uh and he
didn't say this but you know jared it's
like i said man i don't think i don't
think anyone
anyone who like
has bad intentions like they're trying
to be disrespectful
uh i think that maybe they thought you
were trolling i don't know because like
i'm used to dealing with stuff like that
because of the destiny community and the
halo community
so i'm used to dealing with stuff like
that so i know that you're not coming at
a place where you're like upset over
something
but some people aren't like that so
people don't know
oh no
no
there we go
snipers got me man
sniper no sniping
they were pretty uh hardcore with that
they were pretty hardcore with that
uh it's like i said you guys like we
we can have engaging conversations we
can we don't gotta go crazy
look how much damage these things can
take before they're dead
we'll choke
mccain
[Music]
where is
where is it
here it is
that thing is useless
how are you still alive
what was that
i don't know what that was
i feel a little uncomfortable with that
it's kind of so inaccurate man
that really hold i can use the knees
later
that was a waste
let me go get that back
[Music]
pretty good in this game
where's that shot coming from
i like how they drop grenades when you
kill them now
i like how they say grenades they're
acknowledging that i'm spamming grenades
on them
oh god
wow
wow
i need to be a little bit better when i
shoot him hold up let me see this
let's go for another one
kobe
i mean i killed someone but not no one
that was relevant
[Music]
oh my god sometimes you get killed out
of nowhere man
uh
i'll probably stream a lot of destiny uh
in the next couple months on twitch
i don't know yet
i have a love-hate relationship with
destiny
mainly like a hate-hate relationship
with destiny
oh try not to let this thing go crazy
oh
[Music]
bob charlie is now a bearish free zone
hit that terminal and we'll make it
official we still have hospitals all
right kev you have a good day man
appreciate you showing up man showing
out for the unsc
according to banished records we're
right in the middle of some of their
most active transport routes on the
whole ring
these days they mostly support
escheram's excavation efforts but for
most of the war i'm actually enjoying
replaying this game
maybe it's because i'm getting the
achievements because sometimes those
achievements
i i don't
desire achievements but i do enjoy
getting them but that makes sense i know
it's kind of weird but
9 40.
i just picked up a new fob on the
network you're doing right
or if you need anything
i appreciate a bud
yeah the 30-year anniversary stuff's
looking good
when i start streaming on twitch a lot
which is going to be happening soon next
year
um we're streaming the
the video game awards
um i don't know if i'll stream myself
because of the video game awards but i
don't know what to see
you're saying that i'm having
issues with my stream
you guys is it buffering
i don't know if it's buffering or not
the stream was fine a second ago
maybe they just tripping i don't know
all right so let's go up there
hey watch it
i can't believe that dude just told
master chief to watch it
[Music]
the grappling hook makes this game like
when you move around feel like a little
bit like skyrim if that makes sense to
you guys
just a little bit like skyrim
oh
plus i got that reduce
the cooldown by 40 so it's like pretty
quick
i'm picking up a unsc distress signal
not far from this location
i think this is it
oh look it's the uh the thing from the
trailer i think
i'm pretty sure this is the
the thing from the trailers
yeah the stream was definitely having a
little bit of issues there it seems like
it's clear enough though
did i already do this though
i feel like i already did this
um
i feel like i already did this
don't gotta do stuff we already did
oh
i love the grappling hook
i don't know the graphic just never gets
old
that's just my opinion the grappling
hook never gets old in this game
it always feels like really solid
hey i remember this place kind of
reminds me of a halo 1 map or halo 2 map
one of the other
from from the multiplayer
we're in range of captain balcous a
high-ranking brood officer
how about we ruin his day
yeah let's ruin it
going straight for him
i almost escaped
that nonsense
it was so close
but yes so far away
we're gonna get him this time though
oh i like that that was nice
oh my god man
that dude
was like no
see this is like one of the only things
i just really feel like
they could have improved so much
all right now let's get out of here hvt
eliminated now take out the rest of the
squad let's get out of here
get that health back let's start taking
out everyone else
man that suit is so crazy
oh what is that
oh
oh you can still get me over there
oh
oh god okay
they surrounded me
[Music]
if there's a mod in the chat will you
get rid of that
if not i'll get rid of here
oh ravenger
i should have probably grabbed it
let's grab this
done finished
great work
[Music]
to worry about
i bet the rest of the brass are
terrified of you
and if not they sure should be
uh let's see here what's next
so we can go here and rescue lance squad
let's go rescue glad it's gone
ah it's fine uh you know there's only a
little over 30 people in here
might not have a mod in here i could
handle
that it's not a big deal
oh
i think that sword i had ran out or it
should have ran out i don't know if it
did or not
oh i love this man
it gives me like an adrenaline rush a
little bit maybe that
that's
like really bad things about me if that
gives me an adrenaline rush
just a little bit
i was so dead
you know what
let me
let me look for something real quick for
you guys
yeah sometimes it can
there's definitely scenarios where
you can get clap pretty easy
it's more the shield is hella strong
oh
damn i wish i had some type of uh
i don't have a br you must be like
further back in
the stream roadie because i don't have a
br right now
this this is a commando if uh
if you're getting them confused
oh my god just
let me break it already i wish i had
like a
scholar or something like that
but i
don't so uh
i don't got it
i wish i did
oh is that a vr
oh my god for
having my body
definitely it's incredibly detailed it
is pretty detailed i have to give them
that that uh that props
all right hold up how many of you guys
going to be in the reaction tomorrow for
the video game awards
i'm kind of curious
see if i could just break this by just
shooting it over and over again
let me go after that sniper
[Music]
that sniper is the issue
oh there's another sniper i didn't even
see him
oh
got him
they good uh good distraction man we got
good distractions going on right now
let's get this
elite
got him
hold up guys
oh chat we out completely
i hate to do this to you man but one of
you gonna have to switch me oh you won't
switch me
it's messed up
just trying to give him an empty gun
because i couldn't do anything you saved
a lot of lives today these marines are
in your desk yes we will be doing a
reaction to the stream tomorrow we're
probably going live
i don't know what
day
what time it is
let me look what time
what time is the video game awards
2021
it is at 8 00 p.m eastern so
probably be going alive about maybe
seven seven thirty ish that's just me i
still gotta double check what of the
lords is coming
because you know how it is like the
reactions they're different like lord
your disposal sir we don't naturally
everyone show up for those
i'm pretty sure cognito is going to show
up he usually shows up to all the
reactions but he's he's
pretty busy doing his little face uh his
facebook job stuff that he announced
and when um every you guys get a chance
man definitely uh
go and
tag cognito and twitter and congratulate
him for getting that gig over at uh at
oculus man it's really good
proud of my dude man he deserved it
oh my god
what is that shark coming from oh
we got another one another one bites the
dust
unsc distress signal nearby teeth
marking the source oh look at this
sniper trying to snipe me oh god
can you see me oh yeah he can
alright there we go
i'll totally take your weapon though
is there another one
was that the only one
oh let's shoot him
muscle reinforcement inbound
got him
[Music]
i like using the shotgun combo
i don't know i'm gonna use a needler
gets rid of elites and stuff better
got you
oh this is the grunt state
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
all right this should be all
that was rough he lost so many on this
that was rough but now that you're back
they've got a fighting chance at
survival
but we did have that super chat we we
reached our goal today this week
so i definitely appreciate the person
that uh
that uh
super chatted
we have reached our goal
struggle
oh my my head is killing me
just go ahead and take it off we reached
it this week you don't need it up there
[Music]
let's see here
spartan
macro
there's another one just up the road
we'll go to that too
it's pretty high up there though
hold up
i do like that we got that br though
oh
sometimes doing that it's like a
a risky thing sometimes it doesn't work
oh here we go
what's this going on over here
look at that i got a br so i can at
least break that
pulse
that means more marines are in trouble
let's give them a hand
where is the marines okay the marines
are not trapped
but i do got to find that sniper
all right where is that sniper oh i see
him
there's the snipers gone
it is good i'm enjoying it
is there any coils or anything around
here
i would like to throw something at these
people
there's that sniper rifle
hold up
[Music]
i didn't think that thing would kill me
i thought i'd have enough time
i was wrong
it definitely killed me
those things still alive another day
oh my god stop moving
[Music]
there's one reinforcement
two
three
four
let's try not to get as close to
this sniper as possible
okay so there's the dude
we don't want to get shot by that spike
usually a one-shot kill
oh god
how much ammo do we have left we got
enough
oh because of this goes i ain't trying
to do like a one like i ain't trying to
be like that extra
he's invisible she probably yeah
he's got a sword
where is he
oh i gotta get him before he goes
invisible again
no i haven't fought any hunters yet but
that's not this play dude i have fought
hunters in this game before
and they're definitely they could be
problems guys chat they can be problems
get a hundred for doing that
i guess i could go over that and get
together that's a sp yeah let's do that
after i clear this map you know then
we'll
think about doing something else
because i need a sword a new sword
one that's not been used already
let's go up here
yeah
good thing is we got a grappling hook
we're never
not in need of a grappling hook we can
use grappling hooks at any time we want
in this game
yeah they
there's weapons that make them a little
bit easier like the ravager the little
fire weapon
because it burns them from below them
but they are definitely the hardest
thing in the game to fight
they can be very complicated sometimes
man very complicated on legendary i'm
only playing on heroic uh i played a
little bit on the the review build that
i had for legendary
and it it's it's definitely a fun
experience it really is there's no
denying that
oh my god
we're in range of ignovus the devourer
so named because
well he's a brute so you can probably
guess
dangerous doesn't begin to describe this
guy don't turn your back on it
wow
wow
he's he's nothing to mess around with
like he took he hit me three times when
i was going at him hardcore with that
my hat's off to him because
i can't i came from above like i got a
free hit on
we're in range of ignovus the devourer
so named because
well he's a brute so you can probably
guess
dangerous doesn't begin to describe this
guy don't turn your back on you
wow
that is crazy
hitting him like eight times in a row
he's just laughing every time man
every time just laughing
maybe i should try to hit him a couple
times before i try it again
we're in range of ignovus the devourer
so named because well he's a brood so
you can probably guess let me just
dangerously pick them off a little bit
don't turn your back on it
oh my god
i'm gonna get that shield back before i
can do anything
[Music]
this dude doesn't play
he's definitely messing me up a little
bit
and i got a good angle on him maybe i
need to go back and get like a sniper
rifle can i get a sniper rifle out of
the fob
no i can't alright so
that's not an option i could probably
find a sniper rifle if i wanted to
i mean i got a lot of br ammo so maybe i
should focus on him and him only so
named because
well he's approved so you can probably
guess
dangerous doesn't begin to describe this
guy don't turn your back on him
oh that didn't do a lot i thought i was
hoping to do a little bit more damage
than that
i mean i got plenty of ammo
oh god
got it target let's deal with the
leftovers
oh the sniper oh i forgot about him i
forgot about the sniper
oh my god
i didn't get him this time
we're in range of ignovus the devourer
so named because
well he's a brute so you can probably
guess
dangerous doesn't begin to describe this
guy don't turn your back
i on you would stop shooting me
i'mma shoot you just over and over again
like you're not gonna get nowhere man
and your your bullets are kind of easy
to dodge from way up here
when i'm trying to dodge them
okay so he's dead that handles the
target let's get the rest of the squad
i got a little bit of ammo left let's
just chuck grenades down
we have this
yeah let's do this come on
oh that's a sniper
not messing with that sniper again
not dying because of the sniper again
all right where is that thing at
this thing's little this thing's pretty
nice
[Music]
got him
the devourer is no more and if his
dossier is accurate that's a very very
good thing
i am grossed out just thinking about it
you can tell they really planned these
side missions guys that was sniper jack
was yeah i would agree with that
um
this is cool but i i value the vr over
that gun
and now i'm about to run out of ammo
with the br
another squad calling for help chief
we can't leave them hanging
oh
tree climbing
oh
come here
why are you running
why are you running
oh it explodes all right that's useful
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh rocket launcher let's go
yeah
that's not working sorry
enemy reinforcements
he's got a ravager
me
[Music]
thank god for that man that grappling
hook
i switched weapons in the middle of it
by uh didn't i didn't know cut
it done
neither will we
i think that's wrong will end the stream
you guys appreciate everyone for coming
through man i appreciate what's up all
the support we got for today's stream
i will see you guys tomorrow on the
reaction stream to the video game awards
let's go check out 8 p.m we'll go live a
little early probably 7 20 or 7 30 ish
and until next time out of here